thank you it's Mickey Mouse about to
lose his house it seems woke Disney
fairy tales equal low ticket sales box
office analysis of Disney's last Eight
studio releases show a shocking loss of
nearly 1 billion dollars
that's almost a lawsuit
it's gotten so bad cruel DeVille is
selling dogs to Chipotle
Pocahontas had to open a casino
[Laughter]
and Peter Pan had to cancel his gender
affirmation surgery
sorry Peter
that's according to a number crunch by
prominent YouTuber Valiant Renegade who
argues that many of Disney's recent
so-called hits barely broke even or flat
out tanked that includes big budget
Marvel movies like black panther 2
Ant-Man 3 as well as animation bombs
like Strange World and light year and my
favorite Snow White in the seven drag
queens
the latest Indiana Jones also produced
by Disney could suffer a similar fate if
the terrible reviews are anything to go
by it doesn't look good I'm told 80 year
old Indiana Jones spends the entire film
looking for the men's room
for some of us that is a treasure
and what does this say about Disney once
a cultural icon of American Family
Values it's to come to the siren song of
wokism devolving into an out of touch
and desperate divorce dad bereft of
imagination fact is we all liked Mickey
Mouse before he started scolding us
about people's pronouns but lefties can
make you learn to hate everything from
Disney to school teachers to sports
but maybe we're misremembering just how
wholesome their Classic Movies really
were I mean check out this old cartoon
this just in the Irish are moving into
the neighborhood holy those Paddy whacks
are taking over those drunken Catholics
those guys
okay poodle we're gonna have to shoot
our way out of this one oh
they're here
[Music]
this is what happens when you give women
the right to vote
you know okay
Kennedy uh love him or hate the old
Disney they had some good ideas
you know when the women voting thing
hasn't worked out too well
uh what do you what do you uh make of
this uh what's going on with Disney do
you think it's all about woke us I mean
it can't be uh no not necessarily I I
think that they send so much stuff to
Disney plus that it really got
oversaturated and things have to be so
special to spend as much money as we do
going to movies like most people cannot
afford family movie tickets even for a
night so now they have like dine-in
movie theaters where they're trying to
lure you in with nachos and booze which
works for me pretty much every Saturday
night because I'm only buying one ticket
because I leave my cats at home
but if there's something else that's
very creepy about Disney and we have to
bring this up and that's the fact that
the mom dies in pretty much every movie
and Disney has been unable to reconcile
that and now they're all these theories
that like Nemo was killed as well and
his dad is it's like the sixth sense and
he's just looking for the kid who wasn't
there because they all got eaten by the
shark wow I had did not see that coming
at all you know what sucks about Disney
how pathetic it is that you can't sell
Disney that's like not being able to
sell ice cream or something like they if
you want to become have an easy job as a
Salesman you know go work for Ben and
Jerry's where everybody loves ice cream
everybody but they managed to screw up
Disney how can you make it so that
nobody likes Disney you you attack
yourself and that's exactly what they've
done I mean if you look at all the
movies look at movies like Bambi or Fox
and the Hound I mean they tackle life
and death they tackle I mean Fox and
Hound are two animals that are supposed
to want to kill each other like they
tackle real life stuff or they attack
her tackle the completely imaginative
stuff like Peter Pan but even in there
are real world issues that people
actually deal with when you start making
movies that attack that when you start
making movies that that create problems
rather than than literally just
highlighting the ones that exist what is
left for people to identify with when we
want to go watch a movie that's outside
of this world we go watch 80 year old
Tom Cruise fly jet and kill a bunch of
probably Russians but they never really
say yeah you know that that's the kind
of movie we want to see when we watch
Disney wholesome movies with our kids we
want to walk away knowing our kids learn
something about life that we haven't
quite been able to put in the words but
this cartoon helped us figure out you
know what cat Disney should do a movie
about the naked bike riders
[Laughter]
[Music]
could learn something from that thank
you
I don't really think you could learn
anything from that
to be clear
uh but actually well I think Disney
should Rebrand because they are
struggling to make money from their
movies at this point but they make a lot
of money from their corn dogs
yes they can sell a corn dog for ten
dollars at Disneyland anybody else tries
to do that they'll be like get out of my
face but Disney so the movie business is
failing but the corn dog business is
flourishing it is and who doesn't love a
corn dog I really do I know so do the
Naked Bike Ride I knew he was going to
say that
watch them eating that
yeah all right let's go to me
I can boil this down for you for real
like this is actually a semi-serious
point uh here we go the wokism is what's
hurting them though for real because
Disney's core customer is parents right
and they're lecturing parents about
inclusion well they're charging them 200
to get in yeah which is the most
exclusionary thing you've ever heard in
your life is the prices so that's where
it is they're out of touch with the
value of the customer pretty soon
they're going to have a version of
Sleeping Beauty starring Bill Cosby okay
nobody wants that
I'm just saying I like that again
they're blaming you yeah for Bill Cosby
again I got in trouble again I'm not
mixing these drinks what's going on
yeah this is not Bill Cosby yeah I'm not
him there might some confusion
but I'm not quite that good but that's
where it is so on some level I'm I like
watching them tank because they're going
to be forced into a course correction
yeah okay that's the way it always works
yeah everybody always say go too far too
far too far and then they go
they embraced a lot of things that
happens when I'm driving and I keep
going past the bathroom yeah well
you know what you should do you should
sit on a second phone book so it's
easier to see over there
[Applause]
that was yeah I agree that's what
happens to me when I'm too far away from
the bathroom like I'm too far I'm too
far
all right I can't run hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else